welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for Marvel's secret Invasion new
episodes coming to Disney plus June 21st
it's Captain America the Winter Soldier
in the MCU again and I think we are
ready for some spycraft and some
squirrels searches who do you trust well
you can trust this guy to break this
down frame by frame for the details
you missed who has been the squirrel in
the MCU this whole time it's probably
Roadie it's probably ever at Ross Studio
DC Asian clear he's up there for me Val
yeah you're up there too anyway let's
break down this trailer here we go
Fury
Since You've Been Gone
things had gotten much worse the trailer
opens with Fury walking up to a fenced
in sight in the woods looks like an
exclusion Zone because over on the far
left if you look closely as a
radioactive warning sign that gate has
been left open as if this is the kind of
place that you should know not to go in
here we learned in a write-up from
Vanity Fair that part of the series will
take place in a decommissioned
radioactive site in Russia executive
producer Jonathan Schwartz said quote
squirrels are much more able to
withstand radioactivity and there are a
ton of decommissioned radioactive sites
within Russia that's where graphic has
set up his base of operations so gravic
or gravic is Kingsley been a deer's
scroll character the leader of a rebel
group of squirrels who is broken away
from Tallow suspection this Breakaway
group aiming to infiltrate Earth for
resources and Brian Michael bendis's
secret Invasion crossover event in the
comics we learned that many of the
Avengers and high ranking individuals on
earth have been secretly supplanted by
squirrel imposters for quite some time
leading to a paranoid scramble in which
everyone is asking who do you trust the
squirrels in the comics are led by
viranki who had infiltrated the Marvel
heroes in Disguise as Spider Woman
Jessica a Drew but the MCU is in a
different situation Captain Marvel
revealed most of the scrolls are just
friendly refugees of the cruel
imperialistic Cree the Scrolls were
befriended by Nick Fury and Carol
Danvers we saw Talos and his wife Soren
impersonating Nick Fury and Maria Hill
and Spider-Man far from home while the
real Fury was up on a squirrel space
station seems like that's what he's
beating back down from now there was an
interesting line and far from home that
mentioned Cree sleeper cells I thought
Cree having sleeper cells was top secret
information then we saw a scroll in the
one division mid-credit scene recruiting
Monica Rambo to go meet with we assume
Nick Fury and then very briefly there
was a scroll in a track suit being
detained by the TBA in the first episode
of Loki making us all give second
glances to the members of the tracksuit
Mafia in Hawkeye so in the MCU rather
than all squirrels being evil there's a
divide between friendly squirrels like
Talos and the more extremist terroristic
Scrolls like gravic we also know from
that Vanity Fair photo that Amelia
Clarke's character Gia will be in this
radioactive site and Gia is talos's
daughter whom we last Saw playing Uno
with a young Monica Ram bow at the end
of Captain Marvel we know that Gia has
been impatient with telus's ability to
find a new home for the scrolls with
this detail the Scrolls being able to
withstand radiation is pretty
interesting could be something to do
with their exposure to radiation on
different planets and space perhaps
could whatever this radiation source is
be the same source as the exposure that
Monica Rambo might have had as a child
that led to her odd precondition that
showed up on her x-ray scans in one
division activated by further passes
through the cmbr of Wanda's hex barrier
to turn her into Photon now and because
that radiation also be the cause of her
mother Maria's cancer we do see a wide
shot of this radioactive site later in
the trailer and just to be clear this is
not Chernobyl Chernobyl did not have
cooling towers like this they were under
construction when the explosion happened
but they were never finished this seems
to be a completely different radioactive
site also by the way pripyat is not in
Russia it's in present-day Ukraine
that's it there may have been other
radioactive sites that we didn't know
about that just weren't as bad as
Chernobyl chernobyl's just the one that
the International Community found out
about because it was so bad it's
interesting how when talking with sound
Fury goes without the eye patch maybe
his way to show that it's actually the
real fury like his eye scar could be so
unique that it's just too hard to be
impersonated by Scrolls why because it
was scratched into him not by a regular
cap by a flirkin so that we saw in
Captain Marvel
you okay yeah it's just a scratch all
right on to the next trailer clip
oh you think I came back
[Music]
all right we are in moscow's red square
with Saint Basil's Cathedral and the
Kremlin crowded with a Russian Festival
as graphic designates a bomb in a crowd
it's actually pretty similar to a scene
in another great spycraft movie Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol the Kremlin
gets fully wrecked and Tom Cruise has to
run for his life Maria Hill tries to
steady herself in the chaos seems like
the squirrels are trying to incite an
international incident between world
powers the Marvel Studios title card has
been muddied up as of to say we're
getting ready here we're literally
grounding this story none of it's gonna
look like it was shot of the volume
let's hope so on to the next clip
you're in no shape for this fight that
lies before us old friend
[Music]
this is personal all right we jump from
Moscow to London place last saw with
some scroll impersonators Fury flash
Talos Hill slash Soarin and Spider-Man
far from home you can see tower bridge
in the foreground here and that's the
Tower of London on the lower right we
meet Olivia Coleman as Sonia fallsworth
a high ranking MI6 agent who's an old
Ally of Nick Fury is looking to protect
England's national security interests
during this infiltration she's described
its quote a more antagonistic presence
and she could be working with or against
Fury depending on their desired goals
I'm assuming she's something like M from
the Bond movies but her name allsworth
might make her a descendant of James
Montgomery fallsworth who is part of the
hell in Commandos in Captain Bucky's
crew in the first cap film they did
something similar with Jim Morita and
principal Marita in Spider-Man
homecoming Talos tries to grab graphic
in a museum Cafe but everyone around
them turns into graphic including the
server interesting scroll shape-shifting
logic there that their clothes
shapeshift but not their accessories
like their purses and backpacks you know
where do we draw the line there but this
Portrait Gallery has an exhibit the
faces of Freedom including figures like
Winston Churchill maybe the implication
could be that some of these political
leaders that we take for granted could
have been Scrolls like the present-day
politicians seem to be on the show
fallsworth and fury come up upon the
headstone of Colonel Nicholas J Fury
which I assume is this Nick and not like
his dad is also named Nick we know that
Nick did reach the rank of Colonel he
told that to Captain Marvel and that bar
and Captain Marvel film I'm just
questioning this because we already saw
a fake gravestone for Nick Fury at the
end of Captain America the Winter
Soldier with a different quote that
great quote from The Book of Ezekiel
referencing his character Jules and Pulp
Fiction but this quote Grayson love hath
no man the demand laid down his life for
his friend this is John 15 13. different
book of the Bible we just gotta wonder
how many fake Graves Nick Fury has and
does he keep guns at all of them thank
you to better help for sponsoring this
video movies and TV can be great
escapism but when it's time to face
things head on better help is here to
help better help is the world's largest
therapy service and it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues to get started just
answer a few questions about what you're
looking for from therapy and what your
preferences are better help will then
match you with a therapist from their
Network that's right for you after that
talk to your therapist however you feel
comfortable whether that's via text chat
phone or video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge better
help gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy on to the next clip
very few of us know about the walls
fought in the shadows that have raged on
this planet
[Music]
you feel responsible
yeah we see Nick Fury opening a
container in a mausoleum to get a gun
the door to this thing looks like it has
a glowing face of either a wolf or a fox
that lights up yeah I think cury's just
got caches of guns everywhere we get
quick shots of Maria Hill and Everett
Ross Ross we recently saw in Black
Panther were kind of forever defying his
ex-wife and current CIA director Val to
commit Espionage for the wakundance and
at the end of that movie Broken free by
Okoye so he's a man on the run too I can
imagine in a political Espionage show
the CIA director is gonna show up at
some point interesting shot here some
armed soldiers pushed through a car
crash site shooting at attackers
protecting two figures in the center
specifically someone with white hair I
think this is United States President
ritzen Dermot moroni's character and
this is his presidential motorcade after
being struck by missiles we know that
Harrison Ford is going to be playing
president Thaddeus Ross in Captain
America four so I think at the end of
the series something is going to happen
to Ritson either he's gonna have to
resign due to some squirrel related
Scandal or he's gonna get assassinated
GFI is his interesting chamber that's
filled with covered bodies on gurneys
with glowing Parts plugged in the wires
on the floor these are definitely
Scrolls because we saw this shot with
ballsworth in the last trailer but I'm
wondering if these might be soldiers or
super Scrolls that are being kept in
this kind of hibernative state being
prepared to activate in a kind of ground
war onto the next clip
where are the Avengers
this war is one I have to fight alone
okay next week globetrack to what looks
like Paris I want to say from overhead
and someone's reading the French
newspaper Le Globe the headline
translated to The Avengers The Battle of
New York it's really weird to see this
newspaper now the Battle of New York was
like 13 to 14 years ago in the MCU
timeline The Avengers have been involved
in way bigger stuff since then so we
might be seeing a flashback to the year
2012 maybe there was a scroll
impersonator on that world Security
Council that Nick Fury had to answer to
in that film could be connected to that
French diplomat who Ramona sparred with
at the UN in wakanda Forever then we see
graphic from the back of the head as he
enters this room with these curved beams
this must be in that Russian radioactive
site because in the d23 trailer we saw
Gia enter the same room and there is
Russian lettering on the door squirrels
are building something I'm wondering if
they're trying to engineer Bruce
Banner's Quantum tunnel platform because
it does kind of look like that here are
the squirrels trying to go back in time
and change the history so that they
could screw their enemies in the
beginning or are we just looking at a
radiation field that could turn normal
Scrolls into militant super Scrolls no
matter what you think this weapon is but
let's move on you're the most Wanted Man
[Music]
you don't know what they have planned
for you
the Great Neck Fury okay Fury shares a
drink with Roadie who I definitely think
is a scroll it just kind of makes sense
he's like the one of Andrew he's been
there since the beginning who would be
kind of fun to reveal as he scroll
shapeshifter but Rudy calls him the most
wanted man on the planet so Fury might
be framed for one of these attacks
either the Russian bombing or the hit on
the president but then this shot of this
case opening might be the most
mysterious shot of the trailer because
label reads Department of damage control
with specimen sample barcode in the word
cull c-u-l-l what's crazy about this is
this was digitally removed in the same
shot from the d23 trailer so this was
added later call could refer to call
obsidian one of thanos's black order who
was last seen the Battle of wakanda
Avengers Infinity War he was killed when
Bruce Banner strapped his Hulkbuster
armor Gauntlet on his arm instead of
flying grinding against the barrier Dome
until he went boom remember the dodc is
a superhero enforcement agency who has
shown up in Spider-Man no way home and
Miss Marvel and She-Hulk always trying
to gather to protect to keep it under
control and in evidence lockers so who
knows maybe the dodc recovered call
obsidian's hand from Central Park after
it was separated from Wong using that
portal and hacky sack by Bruce there
just seems to be a plot to acquire call
obsidian's Powers I got a theory about
this I'll get to a bit later
okay there's a quick shot of a squirrel
punching a dude with a suddenly massive
cull obsidian-like arm also in this
section we see gravic extending his arm
with some interesting stretchy stretch
abilities which looks like an attack on
britson's motorcade but it kind of looks
like he's shapeshifting into a floor
colossi-like Groot who can't extend the
branches of his arms similarly like this
we might be looking at Super Scrolls who
in addition to shape-shifting to other
people's appearances can also mimic
their super powers and in secret
Invasion Comics we see this with a
Fantastic Four so this series may be
re-engineering that but with established
MCU characters so instead of read
Richards we see the stretchy armed Groot
Powers instead of Ben Grimm we see the
big boy called obsidian instead of
Johnny Storm they could use a fiery
extremist Soldier like that fighter we
saw in the shangchi fighting club and
instead of Sue storm maybe someone with
some invisibility cloaking Tech like we
saw the squirrels using on their space
station in Captain Marvel then there's a
quick shot of Talos with a shot to the
chest as his face is half transforming
into the green skin of a scroll gross
pick a lane dude he does not look like
he's in good shape this could actually
be the person that Gia is crying over
earlier in the trailer we might see
Talos die in this show okay on to the
last clip
one last fight
okay so Fury is leaving that Mausoleum
pops his collar like a badass I like how
the ticks of the trailer music are
slowing down like a clock needing to be
rewound and he says one less fight does
that mean Fury will truly retire in this
will he die in this can Fury ever really
die the show's new title card divides
each letter down the center with a
brighter shade of green on the right to
show the whole theme of dual identity of
this series I love the official poster
for this series an amazing composition
of resembled Stripes of shredded
documents showing Fury's face in black
and white but with a few missing to
reveal the scroll face underneath I
cannot wait for this series I think it's
going to be a nice grounded mystery
thriller spycraft show feeling is
exactly what we need in emcu right now
Captain America Winter Soldier is top
two MCU for me so anything that reminds
us of that film in MCU phase five I very
much approve of let me know what you
love the most about this trailer and
what you're most excited for for secret
Invasion and reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and you
can support a growing Network by
grabbing some merch at nerdright.shop
like this deep dive hoodie you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss follow new rockstars Instagram for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign